[Music]
you fought in in World War two you
served I was like did you see it did you
see any action a little bling
I was short I lived you know they could
shoot over you they shoot over you yeah
listen the army sent me to the army
specialized training programs that we
the VMI on i-17 when I was 18 I was in
the regular army and at VMI I had
studied electrical engineering cosine
tangent slide rules read it and the army
said well since he studied engineering
we'll put him in the combat engineers so
they did and what do you do you you take
a bayonet and you look for for mines
planted mines and they could blow up a
tank I mean they're big they're teller
mines and it says I was to try and fight
with man just until you find them and
unearth them yeah you know really it was
part of the combat engineer's job and if
it could blow up a tank I mean it could
certainly take away a Jew in no time
stream we were extremely careful so and
another job we had was bailing bridges
that's erector sets that you put over
streams one night somewhere outside of
Bonn Hamburg dear emmagan we were
putting together an erector set to put
it over a stream so that trucks could
cross the creek and I heard it was at
night it was late at night true and I
heard yeah yeah yeah yeah
my gosh would Bossi's give out something
yeah yeah I said they're singing the
Germans they're singing so I said I what
the hell I picked up a big megaphone and
I said tut tut tut say goodbye
hey don't cry does it okay and at the
end of my song I heard a little applause
that was my world war two experience
we're glad you made it
uh we taped this show or the knife
what's that not more than all right
oh yeah yeah you're happy too Jana um
cuz your whole life has led up to this
moment right here
not really Dargo you go along with that
please make me feel good I like you I
like you too like I mean I think you're
good thank you yes thank you very much
differ but I think I'm related to those
people